they'll happen in this fight one guy
took them all down with his bare hands
he's still in there turn around mr. miss
your hands slowly
aggravated assault is a felony in this
state mr. Reacher process him and get
him to County two things are gonna
happen in the next 90 seconds excuse me
first that phone over there there's
gonna ring second you're gonna be
wearing these cuffs on your way to
prison
that is one magnificent prophesying mr.
Reacher just gonna keep on ringing
thanks for tipping us off to that
Sheriff
Wendy coming to DC I move around a lot
you're a legend folks wonder why you
left Purple Heart Silver Star there is
this big dent and the dust people say
you made it with someone's headed Jack
creature from agent Turner major Turner
has been arrested on what charge
espionage he could set him
how much does read your know how's it
going I want being followed you think
you're invulnerable that's right
maybe I rip your arm off beat you to
death with it I'm sorry about this
feature you're here to kill you
my men were shot by one of our own this
is bigger than I imagined you ever lose
anyone on your watch Reacher
you're a dead man
you think you above them all
but I'm not the law so you should start
running because I'm gonna start hunting
and when I find you I'm gonna kill you
all
it's a haircut oh you guys go to the
same barber trip hey Sam go see
something crazy let's just sleeping out
right now so do you never seen anything
like this